7.2 magnitude earthquake struck near the
Eastern Aleutian Islands last night
Southern California rocked by a 5-1
magnitude Quake massive effort to try
and search for survivors from the
devastating earthquake there
so you know a century ago we knew very
little about Earth well we knew it had
volcanoes and earthquakes and land
masses and oceans polar ice caps but how
did it get that way was it always that
way these unanswered questions at the
time it really wasn't until the 1950s
where direct measurements were made in
the middle of the Atlantic Ocean the
crust of the Earth was separating and
why did we have good data on that well
the military wants to know what its
submarines will confront under C below
detection so maybe those few continents
that look like they fit together as
puzzle pieces maybe that idea was
correct all along that idea had been
posed for quite some time just take a
look at the west coast of Africa and the
east coast of South America they look
like they kind of fit is that just
coincidence or maybe they used to be one
land mass and then separated the
question about whether they were
together
has been a long one I mean people have
wondered this they checked fossils on
the east coast of South America and on
the west coast of Africa and they
matched but when you take a step back
and realize oh my gosh Earth's crust
moves and you say well at what rate
turns out it moves the continents drift
on Earth's surface at about the rate
that your fingernail grows that's not
very fast in any given moment but it
adds up and the crust is basically rigid
so if it's going to separate or come
together at that rate eventually tension
will build and something's got to give
so either the two land masses pry each
other upwards you make get mountain
ranges that way they can separate and
then you get these sort of uh earthquake
crevasses or one land mass can what's
called subduct can be drawn underneath
the other as the other one crawls up on
its back basically so a lot of different
things can happen when the land masses
encounter one another
it's because Earth is still hot we have
a combination of heat left over from the
formation of the earth plus heat sources
that come from
radioactive elements that are still
within the Earth's volume
and radioactivity sends particles out
that have energy particles get trapped
and it heats up the volume okay we still
have this source of energy and it is so
hot that below the crust below the crust
the material of the earth is not solid
it's like liquid basically it is it is
it is a soft enough solid that it is not
stable
and you have convection
of zones below it that Force
land masses above it to respond if this
is what's happening oh my gosh in one
swing you can explain
earthquakes
volcanoes mountain building all in one
coherent holistic understanding of
what's going on on Earth this string of
islands there's a hole from the mantle
that punches up through the crust and
when that happens you get the magma you
know the molten rocket comes up and you
get lava and you get a volcano then the
volcano goes dormant but you still have
continental drift so what happens the
crush shifts on top of that hot spot and
the hot spot is waiting there to sort of
do its thing again but it's not going to
do it anytime soon you have continental
drift then it's time to be a volcano
again it punches through the crotch
makes another island volcano
then that goes dormant the continents
keeps moving and you get another one
this is how you get volcanic chains of
islands in the world
we have a word for them they're
archipelagos
it's because of continental drift
tragically the zones where you have
these plate movements the boundaries
that's where all the action is that's
where the mountains are that's where the
earthquakes are that's where the
volcanoes are and you can see you can
map this in the world where you are more
likely than not
to expect significant geologic forces to
operate and so no it's not an accident
that you'll find an earthquake over here
and not over there or that volcanoes are
more prevalent there but not over here
but by the way it doesn't mean you would
still feel an earthquake even if you're
far away from one of these zones it
doesn't mean your air wouldn't be
affected by a volcano that exploded
thousands of miles away as the plumes
circle the Earth as it enters the
stratosphere no we're all still affected
by it and especially when you have
municipalities that are near these rings
of fire we call them
those municipalities it becomes not just
simply urgent but it should be a
prerequisite that anything you build in
those areas has some resistance
to an unstable Earth beneath its feet in
the past they look at what buildings
survived and which ones didn't and they
study those and say let's build more of
those kinds of buildings okay so we can
now basically make earthquake proof
build earthquake resistant buildings
because that's where you're going to die
in an earthquake if you're just standing
out in the middle of the Prairie and
there's an earthquake no you're not
you're fine all right it's when the
stuff we build that we occupy collapses
because it cannot sustain the movement
of the ground below it and so you can
make buildings where the the the
foundation of the building
shifts beneath the building and the
building doesn't then move with it the
sliding disses all manners of
engineering Solutions
to enabling a building to survive an
earthquake and by the way we're not
asking for engineering Miracles here
only design your building so that it
doesn't collapse you you still might
have to move out you might have to still
rebuild it or re-anchor it or whatever
but you don't want it to collapse and
that becomes the challenge
earthquakes are very serious when they
happen under the ocean rather than on
land it's a pulse of energy that gets
introduced into the ocean that energy
has to go somewhere so it begins to move
from the ground zero point from the
epicenter of the earthquake and as it
comes to shower and shallower land the
size of the wave grows and grows and
thus you get tsunamis it's one of the
primary causes of tsunamis in the world
Oceanic earthquakes as opposed to
land-based earthquakes
Earth is not going to cool off anytime
soon the earthquakes are here to stay
volcanoes are here to stay we got to
learn to live with them until the day
where we have so good at geoengineering
that we could just sort of go in the
earth and release the stress
or the volcanoes building up pressure
tap it and we tap kegs with spigots
maybe there's a way to release some of
that pressure and control it so that it
never blows catastrophically I don't
know that's in the future of
geoengineering but right now
we're in runaway mode when volcanoes go
off and
rebuild mode after earthquakes that's a
little bit of what's up with that I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]